sarah silverman the comedienne
is is furious at caitlyn jenner because
she says that he is
transphobic with the issue of transports
what does caitlyn jenner
well-known decathlete and guy on the
wheaties box and guy who now dresses up
like a woman what does he know about
transvestitism and
athletics what he doesn't know anything
so sarah silverman
decides to educate him i saw caitlyn
jenner
saying trans girls should not play girls
sports
caitlyn you're a woman right
a trans girl is a girl
she should have the same rights as cis
girls
if you think a trans girl what you think
a trans girl is too strong
i yes what about tall girls
as opposed to short girls what about
boys in high school who are
teeny tiny and their teammates uh have
already hit puberty and are shaving
why don't you just have co-ed sports
divided by weight or height
yeah that's the difference this is so
dumb they are legislating this
without one single example of how this
plays out
this is not worrying about girls sports
uh believe me not i think
there are better ways to worry about
girl sports
this is not worrying about this is not
what that is this is not worrying
this is not concern for girls sports
it's transphobia full stop
okay virtually everything sarah
silverman just said is wrong
and is demonstrably false the
there is no example of this sports issue
being a problem for girls yes there is
there's a very famous case working its
way up the courts right now
represented by the alliance defending
freedom because guess what happens when
the boys play in the girls sports
the boys virtually every time win so
there certainly is a case
trans women are women no they're not
caitlyn jenner you're a woman no she's
not
trans women should have the same rights
as women well they have equality under
the law but men and women are different
so they're treated differently
okay but she does say something
that is useful and true she says
this is not about girls sports and she's
totally right
this is not about girl sports i don't
care about girl sports
i've never watched girl sports maybe if
the olympics is on in the background
i guess i have seen some girls sport
otherwise
i have never watched i've very rarely
watched men's sports
i have not watched women sports i i care
in the sense that it's so unfair
that these girls who run in track to try
to get scholarships and awards
lose them and don't get the scholarships
and go get the awards
because some dude is faster and bigger
and stronger but
generally speaking i don't care about
girl sports what i care about is human
nature
what i care about is the relationship of
my society
and my politics to reality because the
left wants to divorce those things from
reality
and i am pleading i'm i'm clawing with
my
fingernails i'm saying no let's stick a
little bit almost unreality no
and then we fall off of the abyss just
like california is about to fall off
of the united states and sink into the
pacific ocean
sarah silverman says this issue of
distinguishing between men and women and
not letting the men
play in the girls sports even if they
wear a dress and not letting the men go
into the girls bathroom if they're not
even if they're wearing a dress
it's not about the girl's sports you're
right it's not
it's totally not it's about reality
the reason that i can't call caitlyn
jenner
her the reason that i can barely call
him caitlyn i'm sort of going back and
forth
should i just call him bruce caitlyn is
a woman's name it's not a man's name
so if we call caitlyn caitlin aren't we
in
a much lesser degree than with the
pronouns but to some degree aren't we
mainstreaming this i don't know i'm
going back
perhaps i'll go back and forth on the on
the names today
but if we call caitlyn or bruce
her my issue is not about politeness
i don't think it's polite to lie to
people so i don't i don't on that front
i don't think it's necessarily polite to
call him her
but it's not about the sports it's not
about
the way he looks it's not about the way
he talks
it is a little bit about his immigration
policy but that's a separate issue
it's just about the reality of it
i just i won't lie
about something that fundamental okay
i get it politics there's a lot of
scummy people
saying a lot of things that are only
slightly true or not true at all and
there's spinning and there's
there's dishonesty and i i know that
that's true in politics i expect that of
my politicians
but you can't tell me that a man is a
woman and you can't make me
say that i just won't do it it's about
much more to that than that there is
much
much more to lose
gender dysphoria is not the only body
dysmorphic issue that we have going on
this gets to not just bruce jenner's
psychological struggles this gets not
just
to the social contagion where we erase
the distinction between men and women
this gets to a fundamental
misunderstanding
of our relationship to the physical
world all right that was a fun wait a
second
don't nope not just yet ring that bell
subscribe make sure you get
notifications i can't believe i almost
got out of this chair without you have
to do it or you won't be able to see our
videos
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]